[Music]
hi it's lab muffin beauty science here
skincare nerd and really lazy person
today I wanted to talk about some of my
most used skincare and makeup products I
haven't done an empties video in a while
and so I've had a stack piling up and so
I thought I'd share a few sure use of
some of these let me know what sort of
products you want me to review next time
make sure you hit the subscribe button
and the bell if you like videos about
beauty science I'm generally pretty
thrifty with my products and my skin is
pretty oily so I don't end up using a
lot of products that means that I don't
end up using up very many products and
so getting empties is a pretty big deal
for me I'm always testing out new
products and trying out PR samples and
that means I don't really dip into I
guess my favorite products all that much
so if I end up using a product
completely it's a pretty big achievement
I found that the products that I tend to
use up the ones that are pretty reliable
and so I know that they work for my skin
and they're not gonna break me out and
because I am a lazy person a lot of
these are also quite convenient and
quick to use as well so I know that a
lot of people say that packaging
shouldn't be a big deal but in terms of
convenience if you're a bit time poor
then for me personally it's a pretty big
deal if something is a really good
product and it's an annoying packaging
unless it's easy to change the packaging
then I'm probably not going to end up
using it all that much now quite a few
of these are PR samples I've been
blogging since 2011 and I'm pretty
thrifty because I have immigrant parents
I usually don't really buy products that
are in the same category if I already
have one left and so I have a massive
amount of PR samples more than I could
ever use but these are the ones that out
of my stash I've managed to use up and
clearly that means I must be enjoying
them a lot for reference my skin is
normal / oily it's really dehydration
prone and it's really pigmentation prone
as well the first product I've got here
today is the Peter Thomas Roth cucumber
detox foaming cleanser I still have a
little bit left so that I can show you
guys the text
this cleanser is really hydrating it's
got a lot of glycerine in it it's the
second ingredient and glycerin is
probably my favorite ingredient for
dehydration prone skin it's got a lot of
gentle surfactants this Vitter ionic or
non ionic vitro neck means that it's got
two charges that are opposite so it's
got a plus and minus charge non ionic
means that it's got no charge
so I'll click reminder surfactants are
ingredients that are really good at
picking up oil and making it dissolve in
water I talk more about surfactants in a
few of my other videos so like my
micellar water video which I've linked
below so the top ingredients in this
product other than water glycerin coke
emitter propyl butane sodium cocoa and
four acetate and lauryl glucoside
I think one of the main reasons I used
this so much is that it's got this
foaming pomp top which means that when
you squeeze it it comes out as a foam
which makes it really easy to spread and
it also makes it really easy to cleanse
off afterwards as well in general if a
cleanser has this foaming pomp top I'm
probably going to use it a lot as well
as those top ingredients it's also got a
bunch of plant extracts so things like
papaya pineapple and sugar cane which
might have a mild exfoliating effect but
for a cleanser that's not really what
I'm looking for it's a nice bonus though
but what I'm really looking for is
hydrating and effective at cleansing I
also use a double cleansing protocol so
I cleanse with like a balm and then an
oil and then I get into the shower and
then I cleanse with this so if you only
cleanse once this might not be strong
enough for your skin but because my skin
is dehydration prone I find that if I do
to do this double cleansing then my skin
stays a lot more hydrated and it stops
it from feeling tight and dried out the
problem with these foaming pump tops
though is that to make it work the
cleanser has to be pretty watery so you
can see it's pretty much just water or
not just water but you know what I mean
it has the consistency of water or
viscosity if you like scientific words
use this at parties if you hate having
friends so the problem with this is that
because it's already got some water
mixed with it and if firms before like
with a normal cleanser you
rub it to make a firm it means that it
gets used up a lot faster which is a
pretty big downside if you're trying to
save money the other gripe I have with
this product is that it does have the
word detox on it this whole line has the
word detox and the word detox
most scientists hate this work because
most of the time if a brand is talking
about detoxing they're talking about it
in a really non scientific way so
getting rid of toxins which are usually
really poorly defined detoxing is a
legit concept in medicine but it's not
things like drawing toxins out of your
body it's things like Ashlee being
poisoned and getting the poison out or
stopping using a particular medication
so yeah the word detox generally is like
a siren in my hair to be really cautious
about what claims it has but this is a
really nice product despite this I just
wish they get rid of the word really
next up I have the pharmacy green clean
makeup melt-away cleansing balm this is
a soft light green balm that's actually
a really pretty color it comes with a
really handy spatula to dig out your
product and the spatulas attached to
this plastic insert and the lids are one
of those sealing inserts and I hate
taking it off and on so what I ended up
doing was I chucked out the insert and I
just shoved the spatula right into the
middle of the balm um it's really good
at removing makeup as most cleansing
balms are and the nice thing is that it
rinse it off really cleanly it has a
kind of peppermint scent it's pretty
mild it's got a few actors in it it's
got some antioxidants like the echinacea
green envy extract but with cleansing
product slider really get them full the
active so I guess again it's a nice
bonus but it's not one of the main
reasons I want a product now this
product does contain polyethylene and a
lot of people have asked me if this
polyethylene counts as micro plastic
waste and the hard answer is I don't
really know
so you might know microbeads which are
the scrubbing grains of plastic that you
get in a lot of scrubs but the vast
majority of micro plastic waste in the
environment doesn't come from beauty
products it's from laundering synthetic
fabrics and from tires so with synthetic
fabrics
whenever you wash any sort of plastic
base clothing like polyester and acrylic
tiny fibers break off as your clothes
are bashing around inside the laundry
inside the washing machine and these
tiny fibers can't be filtered out by
your washing machine filter and so when
all the water washes through your
clothes and washes off all the detergent
the water makes its way into the ocean
carrying these tiny fibers along with
tires on your car and on trucks when you
break a lot just just with wear and tear
really the ties break down and tiny
particles come off onto the road and
then blow away into the ocean or go down
the drain and eventually go into the
ocean now no one really knows exactly
what the extent of the impact of micro
plastics are but so far with studies it
looks like it's not great for things
like fish but given that the plastic in
this and in other cleansing balms is
really really small in size too small to
Ashley C it probably won't have the same
sorts of effects as larger particles
that fish will eat and because there
aren't as many particles in this
compared to a scrub I think the impact
on the environment is pretty minimal I
do think it would be nice if they got
rid of it and managed to replace it with
a non plastic ingredient it's mostly in
there for thickening rather than
scrubbing like Oh polyethylene normally
would be in a scrub but because the size
is so small and I think the amount is a
lot lower as well then I think the
effect is mostly insignificant compared
to all of the other contributions like I
mentioned in the video on coral and
sunscreens I think focusing on the tiny
amount of plastic and things like these
cleansing balms
is kind of like rearranging deck chairs
on the Titanic
it's kind of missing the main point and
it's a bit of a
not a major concern the texture of this
bomb is also really nice it melts onto
your skin quite nicely and I personally
prefer using bombs to oils these days
because with a cleansing balm you put it
on your face and then you can step into
the shower without worrying about it
dripping all over your face and dripping
onto your clothes and onto the floor and
that sort of thing it's also a lot
easier to transport them from your hand
onto your face you don't have to like
slap your face really fast to get all of
the liquid onto there because it only
melts when it gets on your face you
don't have to use very much either it
spreads really smoothly and quickly so
you're really nicely formulated product
um so the shoe your mirror cleansing oil
I've actually used it up and chucked out
the bottle and so this is my new bottle
that I'm holding here and show you guys
it's very new the one I'm using is the
ultimate sublime beauty cleansing oil
sheer marys started the whole cleansing
oil craze about fifty years ago and
they've got a whole bunch of different
cleansing oils I think the last time I
checked it was about six different oils
and one gets sold about every second
seconds worldwide at the time I bought
it this was the newest and fanciest one
it's got a pretty long ingredient list
and it looks like the main oils and
surfactants are pretty varied so for
oils there's corn
there's ethyl hexyl Parma tea which has
like a nice Glide
it's got caprylic and capric
triglycerides which is the same as MCT
oil so medium chain triglycerides from
coconut oil which is pretty popular in
nutrition at the moment there's also
isopropyl myristate which is not very
greasy and there's also a bit of meta
foam seed oil as well there's also a
bunch of different surfactants in there
as well they're all gentle and non-ionic
and they have lots of glycerin molecules
inside these surfactants so if they stay
on skin they're going to be quite
hydrating as well they're all poly
glycerol esters and there's also the
fact that if you have a mix of
surfactants inside a product it usually
means that it's more gentle and these
surfactants don't get into your skin and
cause prolonged irritation and if
disturbs your skin a bit less as well
again I'm really into convenience and so
the pump lid is probably one of the big
reasons why I end up using it so much I
sound like the laziest person right now
and that's because I am this cleansing
oil is pretty thick it's not super thick
so does
feel like it's clogging my pores but
it's thick enough that getting it onto
my face that is not a big issue I don't
end up splashing it everywhere so this
cleansing all--if dissolves makeup
really quickly it washes off really
cleanly and my skin feels really soft
afterwards and because of that a lot of
the time I don't even bother with a
second glance when I use this because my
skin just feels really nice and I don't
want to I guess of wrecked that feeling
it is a bit pricey but you don't really
need to use all that much you only need
like one pump half a pump for me at
least with my particular makeup and so
this one is a solid favorite I have
repurchased it I will probably continue
to repurchase it unless a cheaper one
comes along
I bought its skin citron peeling gel
from Rose rose shop I bought three
different peeling gels and this one's
been my favorite it has a really nice
refreshing citrus scent smells a bit
like a cleaning product which I actually
quite liked it works really well in the
shower with my appealing gels I use them
after cleansing and so usually I'm in
the shower I want to rinse it off in the
shower because it's a lot easier than
stepping out again lazy a lot of peeling
gels aren't really dense enough though a
bit too watery to bunch up properly to
form those little rolling fibers that
drew all the physical exfoliation for
you and so a lot of them feel like I'm
just rubbing my face with my fingers
when I use them in the shower
this one is dense enough that you can
feel stuff on your skin this peeling gel
contains 1200 milligrams of yuzu extract
I'm not really sure what it's meant to
be doing there I assume it's for
brightening and I couldn't find the
ingredients list translated online but
there's a similar product from its skin
and it looks like the main ingredient
for peeling is cellulose with peeling
gels I found that most of them are kind
of similar if they bunch up properly so
I'm actually trying a few more so I
haven't repurchased this but I would
repurchase it if I wasn't finding more
peeling gels at the moment my next empty
is the face shop rice water bright lip
and eye makeup remover this is one of
the face shops bestsellers and one of
the things I notice about it that's
different from other ones is that it's
one of those I am lip makeup removers
that have the true phases and with this
one after you shake it it stays mixed
for ages like it stays mixed for days so
if you really don't like having to shake
it all the time then this is probably
the one for you it has a moderate scent
it's kind of powdery I'm not a huge fan
of the scent and that's probably the
main reason that I'm not planning to
repurchase it one of the other things I
really like about this from my
convenience
laziness point of view is that the lid
is really good for opening with wet
hands so the lid has this sort of divot
which means that you can get a really
good grip on it you don't have to worry
about closing a too tight you can easily
open it even if your hands are wet and
covered in cleanser it doesn't sting
your eyes it has a little bit of a
residue but the residue feels more
hydrating rather than oily which is a
problem with a lot of other true phase
makeup removers it's pretty effective it
gets everything I use off video overall
pretty good product not a huge fan of
the scent this is the body shops fresh
nude foundation I use barley vanilla
which is o2 R and at the moment my skin
is in Mac about an NC 20 this is a
pretty neutral shade it's a little bit
yellow tinged which works quite well for
my skin and I'm actually wearing it
right now it's a medium coverage
foundation that gives me a pretty jewy
finish but my skin is quite oily it does
move a little bit on my skin throughout
the day I just use this all the time
because it's just reliable when it does
move it's a good enough color match that
it doesn't look obvious it doesn't bunch
up a lot as well it does kind of settle
into this line here sometimes but in
general it doesn't move very much
there's quite a few shades and this one
is a really good color match for me and
there's actually a pretty impressive
shade selection especially since the
body shop
mostly doesn't do makeup it's got SPF 15
but to be honest you're not really
putting on enough foundation to get much
SPF coverage with this to apply it I use
a damp sponge and that works really well
it's also pretty inexpensive so it's
about $32 in Australia which is really
good for a foundation
I've already repurchased this one it's
got a nice texture
it isn't really silicone II it doesn't
break me out it's not particularly long
where but I don't really need long where
most of the time I see a big fan of this
one so that's it for my empties this
time I hope you enjoyed this video make
sure you subscribe and hit the
notification button if you want to find
out more about beauty signs you can also
follow me on Instagram for more beauty
science tips and myth-busting as well as
occasional reviews as well there's also
my blog which has tons and tons and tons
of articles on beauty science see you
next time - nerd out more about beauty
you